So our goal is to make a seemingly impossible domino run that you have never ever seen before
Clint
You want to get our social distance measurements?
Back up
You know, you're defeating the point if you're actually touching people with these things
So Nvidia sent us these new laptops that have really nice workstation GPUs in them
They're the uh, the Quadro RTX
And these GPUs not only are they great for 3D rendering and video editing and all that kind of stuff
But you can also do physics simulations on them
So what better way to take advantage of a workstation GPU
Than to do a physics simulation with thousands and thousands of objects
Let's team up. You guys are CG Wiz kids.
I ain't so bad myself and let's make an impossible. Domino's run
Let's make a video real quick dude, let's just make a video real quick
Dude I'm sorry,
You're touching the end of it right now!
I actually love dominoes man. I mean when I went to comic-con like 10 years ago, dude
We built a domino run that turned on the lights. It's controlled destruction. I think that's what's so satisfying about it. It's this very
Intricate cool looking design one false move and the whole thing just is wrecked. I feel like there's so much hype with these things
It's like the same crowd who goes to watch a building demolition is probably watching these videos, too
the thing I like about domino's is when you can actually scale up the size of them because
A domino can knock over another domino. That's one and a half times bigger
You can scale that up
But the problem is that if you're doing that for real you end up hitting this barrier called reality
Where you can't make anything bigger than that?
Do you think it's like cheating to do it in cg instead of doing it? For real? No?
No
You embrace the cg like a computer simulation of a domino effect is just as satisfying if not more
Satisfying because you have to consider the fact that you can do the impossible in cg
But you're still using real life dynamics to control and set up the impossible
So it's still real physics like you still have to make the physics work. Yes
So our goal is to make a seemingly impossible. Domino run that also looks real
You will see a domino run that you have never ever seen before
I think we can do it in three shots each one growing in complexity and maybe even a scale of the dominoes as well
We start with the first one like in the studio or something doing like some crazy cool little pattern going along the ground
Then it goes and hits a diamond formation that makes the corridor logo
In the middle of the floor here and then continues onto the wall
It's about to go out the door and it goes up the wall
Maybe it goes around the corridor logo. How do you change the direction of gravity? You're not a windrunner?
How do you get it to go up the wall?
You would have to do it in two separate simulations and you'll just take that entire second domino scene and rotate it 90 degrees
And just put it up against and then just line it up
It's technically three separate sims because you have one up to the wall two going here
three
Restarting normally and dropping here and then it disappears around the corner and then we just cut to outside
We have a little line goes zoop out to here
And it goes ding ding ding ding and then I get to like click size dominoes, right?
It'll just be a snake down the road and then
What happens I mean red has this drone so then we can scale them up to the point that they're bigger
Than any dominoes can physically exist in real life really leveraging the use of cgi here, right? It'll be so cool, man
Oh, hold up. We're going to be filming an invisible. Domino run. Yes, and we don't know how fast they're going to move
So I think what we need to do is we need to set up like a two scale
20 foot long domino run on the computer and see how fast that moves dang to be
So sick if we could just like do this right now on the spot, but oh wait, this is actually perfect
Can we just take a moment to appreciate that clint is using his thigh as a mouse pad, dude
It's the best mouse pad honestly 20 feet. Yeah, let's do 220 feet. All right, i'm gonna hop into the shade here
Hey milo
milo
Hello
Hey milo
All right, nico, let's let's focus on the important things. Um
So i'm gonna take a second here and talk about the hardware we are using so this is the razer blade studio
It has an nvidia rtx quadro in it. So that's a really fancy version of a graphics card. And what makes this different
well
It has more vram
Vram's useful for like when you have to have textures on the card for your 3d scenes like when we render stuff in octane
Or in the case of uh, if you're doing like machine learning you need to hold like bigger models on it or for example
If you're working with like 8k red footage another thing that's really important to having a good workflow is having good drivers
So nvidia has their studio drivers out now which accelerate things like adobe premiere and after effects or cinema 4d for example
So that it fully utilizes their gpus to run fast and smooth
So in this case, we're going to be doing a bunch of physics simulations with a bunch of rigid body objects
All these kind of things really benefit from good gpu integration and that's what nvidia has with their nvidia studio drivers good
Are you done yet? Yeah, actually this is actually going at a rate of
Immigrant song this domino line is going five feet per second
If you walk to the tempo of immigrant song by led zeppelin you will be walking at five feet per second
You know
That's about the space you want to walk
That speed is only for that size of domino
If you were to increase the size of that domino, that speed is actually going to increase pretty substantially
So we know the speed of the regular size dominoes
Let's go ahead and make a two foot tall version of that same domino
And just like literally run the simulation to see how fast that is
Come to the land of the ice and globes snowing time, it's time to go
dang that moves quick
Hey ren, we have our answer. Can you ride at 13 feet per second 13 feet per second
How many miles per hour is 13 feet per second? Oh, yeah, that's nine miles an hour. That's slow
I easily hit 20 miles an hour right there
All right. So rent can go the right speed we have to plan for our shots now
We just have to execute
Right now ren's going to go out and get the drone shot while clint and I start working on building our domino sequences
And you might wonder why we're on the laptops in the studio
Well outside of the fact that the uh, the gpus are fast for physics simulations see ren's computer isn't here
We took our computers home
So actually it's a really good thing that we have these laptops to work on in the studio because our computers are all gone anyways
So i'm basically piecing together three simulations because you have one up to the wall two going here
three
Restarting normally and dropping here
And then once we have the footage i'll be able to tweak the spline path and all this and that it'll look real nice
Nico is actually going to build a really cool corridor logo made from dominoes. Um shouldn't take too long
I'll just be using black and white dominoes
I'll just set it up and i'll test it out knock them down and i'll move on from there
I'm digging. I keep messing up my shot. Look at all these trucks messing up my dominoes. All right, you ready?
They're getting bigger they're getting bigger. Oh no, it's gonna hit the highway boom
All right
Nice all right guys, I got the shot
So this would be the corridor logo right here
five foot diameter
How long is it is the logo gonna take to fall down?
I need to have that in my mind as i'm actually recording all of it. So nico. There we go
Freaking two and a half seconds three seconds to be exact. That's really cool, man
This computer handles like a thousand objects like it's nothing at some point
I'll get to where I kind of like come up and i'm looking down at the quarter logo, and I just kind of hold it
The dominoes get to that point before I get there
You just add some more snake turns and if I get to the logo before the dominoes have gotten there
You just remove a couple snake lines exactly
Ready?
That takes us to shot two which is out on the street which one will shoot on the one wheel
Sweet we got it? All right
Okay, uh, we're good I think we got it I think this will work so clint yeah, here you go
Oh, wow, I actually caught it. I'm actually really excited about how this is going to turn out
So excited about how this is going to turn out like this is the freaking stuff
I'm excited for you. If you're watching this video, you're not subscribed to corridor crew for you to subscribe to corridor crew, please subscribe
All right
See ya. See you man
These cats are just roaming dude. Look at these things
So we have to make these dominoes look super realistic and there's a few things that I want to go over with you guys
On how i'm going to achieve that ren did a great job tracking the footage so it's seamless on that end, right?
So the first thing I want to do is reference dominoes and get the look of a domino
You want to make sure your dimensions are correct?
And then from there we're going to use an hdri
Which is basically just a bunch of images bracketed at different exposures combined together to give us the most realistic
Lighting sphere here. So if I just navigate around our scene here, you can see that we're kind of going around this hdri
Image that ren took of the studio and that's what's actually going to help us fuse these dominoes
With the actual live-action footage now when we're in the exterior scenes, what i'm doing is basically adding sunlight here in octane
You can see how this gets like a real nice
Realistic middle of the day type look here catch the swing there
The next thing we need to do to those dominoes is add a number of surface
Imperfections that's going to be one of the things that is really going to push this domino
Above and beyond in terms of realism because it's not a perfect domino right out the factory gates
So this is a fingerprint surface imperfection by cornelius domrick
And that makes things shiny and also makes things rough and it just mixes it all up
So it looks like someone actually touched these dominoes with their grubby old fingers
And that goes a long way when these things are getting knocked over one by one and they're catching the glare
Of the light from above it's really gonna look nice when it's not just a perfect factory glare
So that's just a few ways to really step up the render here the graphics card and these laptops
Really make it easy to render quickly
All right, so clint just called me he is ready to show us the final shot so let's take a look
Clint, I hope that hair clip kept your hair out of your face by doing these intense physics simulations
Unfortunately, this is the only time I had my hair clip up so I couldn't see anything the whole time
So hopefully these shots are good
Yeah, i've been working on this stuff for the past three days
I don't know. I'm a little nervous. I know those vfx eagle eyes are just ready, um to strike
So tear me apart, dude, my eagle eyes can see an alias pixel from a thousand feet away
All right. I am ready for this. Here we go
The forest, oh looks good that that little bit of shine yeah, it's all about the shine
a little bit of steps you got
You've got some
Quarter logo. Yeah looks nice. All right up the wall
Oh you get just a little bit ahead of it, I remember we talked about that, but other than that looks pretty good
Boom it looks really good. It looks real real. Like it looks realistic the lighting and everything looks great. I think ren's hdri
That he took of the studio. That's
Huge in making something realistic is that hdri? I think it's catching the glare really nicely right here
Looks like you're just kind of like flying over the ocean catching those highlights
You know and it was tough just because like I had to basically sync up
The speed of these dominoes to the timing of the video. Yeah. It was actually pretty difficult physics man. It's chaos
It's nature. I want to see the next shot. Yeah, dude. I want to I want to see the outside shot
Wait, it just starts already halfway through. Yep. Oh
Already letting me go down. I wanted to see the transition from the tiny to big. It's too fast. Wow
The dominoes are out pacing around on the one wheel
Red is magically flying over the dominoes. Yeah. Yeah
Wow, the rendering looks great though. Yeah realism is like spot on
Yeah
It's all about that glare and I think you can actually see the surface
Imperfections here when they catch the sun and the fall off to just like the normal kind of look that
Is definitely one of the things that makes this thing look as real as it does. Here's the thing though. Here's the thing
There's a glaring error. There's a glaring mistake in this shot. I feel like the sun direction doesn't quite match to that truck shadow
Absolutely, not. Look at the shadows on the dominoes, right?
It's like basically top down lighting. I was looking at the dumpster and I was like, ah, that's pretty top lit, you know
And why I didn't see this freaking shadow of the telephone pole
Yeah, so 45 degree angle for the sun
So I actually tracked these shots in after effects using the ae camera tracker which isn't the best camera tracker
But it's the easiest to use really this is an attraction after effects. It's impressive. Oh, yeah. No, it tracks super easy. Nico
You know you were giving me the old gripe about not having dominoes go from small to big well, dude
Well, do I have a shot for you? Oh, man, here we go. Oh the last shot. There's a downhill transition. I wanted to see
The first thing gets a little crooked. I like that. Oh, no, we're out man
Oh, man, whoa
Wow, love you that you can actually see the bounce light from the other dominoes
Dude I didn't know you're gonna do this
Yeah, I ended up just going with a freaking giant domino explosion at the end. It works. What a way to end it really well
Some of these dominoes have minds of their own and they start taking flight flying around like little bats, you know, they're agitated now
Cool well nice work man. I looked great
I think we've learned a lot about how we should actually go about
Timing up footage and and the dominoes what we have here is really cool
And it's really promising for doing a crazy corridor video where you push us even further and put some more time into it
Well, dudes. I look forward to doing some more domino setups on these laptops. So yeah
All right
Well that turned out great clint did an awesome job
And being able to do these kind of shots on a laptop was super cool
It actually it unlocks a lot of creative potential for us to be out like on the street with
One of these guys doing physics simulations and ray tracing rendering being able to edit out in the field in the middle of a shoot
With 8k red footage on the spot to see how it looks so having mobile power is awesome
If you end up picking up one of these nvidia studio laptops
You actually get three months free of adobe creative suite so go check it out link is in the description below. All right everybody
Thanks for watching and don't forget to check out the corridor channel where eventually we'll be posting another domino video. That's youtube.com
Corridor. Alright. See you later
So snoop dogg has asked me to bring tupac back to life for music video
Through new visual effects newly shot scenes 200 to you a reimagined version of charlie and the chocolate factory
I'm gonna put a nerf blaster on a drone. I wanna hit your drone out of the air challenge accepted
You